I was never really an ideological
conservative in the sense that I
believed that the free market is always
right I was more somebody who put
caution before beside innovation
whenever innovation had to be considered
and they would try my best to see what
were the you know the downsides of
something as well as the upsides and I
think there is always in any political
system a need for a strong conservative
voice in that sense that looks at the
effect on the overall organism of the
change that's proposed rather than as
whether the particular change is merit
in it of itself and that sort of
conservatism is something that will
never die and will always be necessary
and it's quite different from you know
radical free-market thinking which in
fact in some respects can be anti
conservative because it can cut away
some of the undermine some of the sort
of social habits that people have of
solidarity for others of charity of know
providing perfection and security for
people because those don't go here
exactly with the free market so the free
free-market ISM feeling free
marketeering
can in fact be anti conservative rather
than conservative in depending on their
on the circumstances and anyway it's
only a means to an end the free market
is a means of delivering welfare to
people and prosperity it's not an end in
itself whereas conserving what's good
while adapting is something that is good
in itself I would describe myself first
and foremost as a Christian Democrat
rather than as a conservative because I
think and I'm practicing Catholic but I
think you don't have to be a practicing
any religion to recognize that
Christianity moderated some of the most
extreme aggressions that were seen in
pre-christian Europe by you know
creating a sense of responsibility to
one's fellow
of loving one's neighbor of of a sense
that you know there was a next life and
that's what you did wrong here could not
be to your advantage in the next life
and therefore there's quite apart from
whether the police might catch your own
interest was just here that you should
behave yourself in a reasonable way
relative to other people those were
restraining issues that were promoting
also social justice that emanate from
Christianity and that's why I think I'm
happy to be described myself as a as a
Christian Democrat and that's a strong
European tradition as well
Chancellor Merkel of Germany is a
Christian Democratic too but I hope
there are elements of conservatism in
Christian democracy but also there are
elements of